Greta Gerwig is bringing Barbie to life on
the big screen, but is a movie about a doll
just toying around, or will it somehow break
the mold?
Here's all you need to know before checking
out the latest toy-turned-blockbuster.
If you're a movie lover, then you've no doubt
circled July 21 on your calendar.
After all, it's the most important day of
2023.
Why's that?
"How about because this is the most important
thing to ever happen in the history of the
world!?!"
On that day, two phenomenal films will hit
theaters at the same time and go head-to-head
for box office dominance.
July 21 will play host to "Barbie" — a colorful,
zany comedy — and Christopher Nolan's "Oppenheimer"
— a grim, heavy biopic.
Regardless of which film does better, it's
a win-win for cinephiles, as both films look
like they're going to be absolutely exceptional.
When it comes to the movie's plot, the official
"Barbie" website has provided a short-but-sweet
summary, which reads,
"To live in Barbie Land is to be a perfect
being in a perfect place.
Unless you have a full-on existential crisis.
Or you're a Ken."
Unfortunately for our ever-smiling hero, it
looks like she's having that crisis.
In the film's official main trailer, we see
how her perfect life is falling apart.
Her morning shower is ruined by a sudden surge
of cold water.
While she used to easily float down from the
roof of her house into her cute Barbie car,
now she's just falling straight to the ground.
And instead of feet that always perfectly
mimic the shape of a high heel shoe, suddenly,
her soles are flat on the ground — the horror.
"FLAT FEET!
BLECH!"
Most alarming of all, Barbie is suddenly haunted
by thoughts of death.
Hoping to find answers to life's big questions,
she decides to venture out into the real world,
with a stowaway Ken tagging along.
Unfortunately, this is frowned upon by the
executives at Mattel, the company that makes
Barbie toys.
When our blonde hero leaves Barbie Land behind,
the suits do everything in their power to
hunt her down.
Will they put her back in the box before Barbie
can figure her life out?
The trailers for "Barbie" have all been pretty
incredible.
The first "Barbie" teaser was a hilarious
homage to "2001: A Space Odyssey," with a
tribe of little girls ditching their baby
dolls when a gigantic Barbie shows up on the
scene, standing in for "2001's" eerie monolith.
The second "Barbie" teaser got even zanier,
complete with Beach Boys tunes, the bright
pink hues of Barbie Land, and every character
greeting our bubbly blonde protagonist.
"Hi, Barbie!"
"Hi Barbie!"
However, it's the film's main trailer that
really drives home the plot — showing the
cracks that are starting to show in Barbie's
seemingly perfect life.
With thoughts of death swirling around her
head, Barbie is given a "Matrix"-like choice
by Kate McKinnon's character.
She can either pick the high heel and stay
in her regular life or pick the sandal and
go on a journey of exploration.
After a bit of prodding, Barbie and Ken set
out on a highly stylized journey to the real
world.
Of course, as the trailer shows, the real
world is no cake walk.
Barbie even winds up in jail!
However, as she searches for meaning, Barbie
never gives up hope, and the trailer promises
that this wacky comedy is going to go to some
serious places.
"Ideas live forever."
"Barbie" features one of the best casts we've
seen in a long time.
Margot Robbie stars as the titular doll, which
is perfect casting, as she looks exactly like
Barbie.
And since Robbie has played wildly varied
characters in projects like "The Suicide Squad,"
"I, Tonya," and "Once Upon a Time in Hollywood,"
we know her spin on the iconic character will
be something unique.
Of course, you can't have Barbie without Ken,
and Ryan Gosling is stepping into the role
of the blonde boy toy, which is another casting
triumph, since Gosling looks like a walking,
talking Ken doll.
And while he excels at playing quiet, brooding
men, he's also great at over-the-top comedy,
as evidenced by "The Nice Guys."
"I had to question the mermaids!
What were you doing while I was working?"
As for the rest of the cast, this is where
things get incredibly funny.
Most of the actresses are all playing different
versions of Barbie, and most of the actors
are playing various versions of Ken.
For example, Issa Rae is President Barbie,
Ritu Arya is a Pulitzer-Prize–winning Barbie,
and Dua Lipa is Mermaid Barbie.
Playing a whole host of Kens — whose defining
characteristic seems to be the fact that they're
all just Kens — we've got Simu Liu, Kingsley
Ben-Adir, Ncuti Gatwa, and Scott Evans, just
to name a few Kens.
Michael Cera of "Arrested Development" fame
also lives in Barbie Land, but he's a bit
of an oddball.
Instead of playing a Ken, Cera is playing
Allan, a character based on a discontinued
1960s toy that was made to be Ken's best friend.
Similarly, Oscar-winning screenwriter Emerald
Fennell will play Midge, another less-famous
toy who was at one point canonically married
to Allan.
Rounding things out, Will Ferrell will play
the CEO of Mattel, Helen Mirren will narrate
the movie, Rhea Perlman of "Cheers" fame will
also show up, and famed wrestler-turned-actor
John Cena will reportedly appear as a merman.
"Barbie" marks Greta Gerwig's third film as
a director, but while she's only helmed three
movies, Gerwig is one of the most exciting
filmmakers in Tinseltown.
She first sat down behind the camera for "Lady
Bird," the coming-of-age dramedy that earned
multiple Oscar nominations, including one
for best picture and two for Gerwig — best
director and best original screenplay.
She then reunited with Saoirse Ronan for a
beloved adaptation of "Little Women," which
earned a best picture nod at the Academy Awards
and also nabbed Gerwig an Oscar nomination
for best adapted screenplay.
In other words, when Gerwig gets involved
with a project, you can bet that film will
turn out to be gold — even a concept as
crazy as "Barbie."
While a guest on Dua Lipa's podcast, "At Your
Service," Gerwig talked about her experience
making the upcoming film, saying,
"It was terrifying.
[…] That feeling that I had was knowing
that it would be really interesting terror.
Usually that's where the best stuff is.
[...] Anything where you're like, 'This could
be a career-ender,' then you're like, 'Okay,
I probably should do it.'"
Gerwig also wrote the script, alongside Noah
Baumbach, her romantic partner.
Similar to Gerwig, Baumbach is also a highly
respected director, having helmed movies like
"Marriage Story" and "The Squid and the Whale."
The Barbie Dreamhouse is a legendary estate,
and the "Barbie" movie design team has done
the palace extra proud — and extra pink.
Production design and set decoration dream
team Sarah Greenwood and Katie Spencer drew
inspiration from mid-century modern mansions
and real-life toys, plus director Gerwig's
references — which, according to Architectural
Digest, range from the bold "Pee-wee's Big
Adventure" to the pastel-powered fever dream
of "An American in Paris."
The result is a Dreamhouse that looks like
"Mad Men" meets Nicki Minaj.
The design of the Dreamhouse is inspired by
"the Kaufmann House," a Palm Springs home
designed in 1946 by Richard Neutra.
While Neutra's work favors neutral shades,
Greenwood and Spencer had a mandate of their
own to follow: think pink.
The team used so much pink paint it caused
an international shortage, but not all of
that paint was on the Dreamhouse itself.
The beautiful backdrops that surround Barbie
Land are hand-painted, not CGI, partly in
keeping with what Gerwig calls the "authentic
artificiality" of Barbie's world.
The home is full of bright colors and toy-like
details.
Even Barbie's closet is clearly designed to
match the packaging of clothes sold separately.
Still, a quick glance at Barbie's movie home
shows that there is a price to be paid for
living a "perfect" life.
Gerwig explained to Architectural Digest,
"​​Dreamhouses assume that you never have
anything you wish was private.
There is no place to hide."
Barbie and Batman have a lot in common: names
that start with "B," extreme wealth and style,
absentee parents — so it only makes sense
that they also share the same taste in automobiles.
The "Barbie" movie's Dream Car was designed
by the same artists who made the Batmobile
for Robert Pattinson's "The Batman."
While this batty collaboration has us hoping
for an influx of street-legal hot pink Batmobiles,
we won't hold our breath — unless it's for
another potential, electric, and real-life
Barbie car tie-in.
Barbie's movie ride is a custom pink electric
Corvette.
Eagle-eyed viewers of the "Barbie" trailers
can spot an electric charging port and a blue-highlighted
"EV" in the "Chevrolet" script on the side
of the Dream Car.
When Fox News reached out to Chevrolet regarding
possible real-life Barbie cars, Chevrolet
provided a response:
"Barbie and Corvette have had a long-standing
relationship and we're excited to build on
that in the 'Barbie' movie.
More to come on this and some other surprises."
Autoevolution reports that GM has confirmed
that electric Corvettes are slated for release
soon — so why shouldn't some be pretty in
pink?
Barbie and pink go together like, well, Barbie
and Ken.
But production design and set decorator collaborators
Sarah Greenwood and Katie Spencer had to get
the right pinks for the "Barbie" movie — pinks
that would sustain the dreaminess of Barbie's
world, as well as convey the playful, toy-like
quality of her "real" life.
Finding the perfect pink was no easy task.
The designers narrowed their scope from 100
pinks to a range of 10 to build the look of
the film.
According to IndieWire, Gerwig named the color
palette "Techni Barbie," in reference to "Technicolor,"
a suite of film color processes that was popular
with movie musicals like "The Wizard of Oz"
and "The Red Shoes."
Rodrigo Prieto, who shot "Brokeback Mountain"
and "The Irishman," is no stranger to colorful
films.
He also shot "The Wolf of Wall Street" and
"Broken Embraces."
His artistry across styles is put to use by
the "Barbie" movie.
While we barely get a glimpse of the "real"
world in the "Barbie" movie, one thing's for
sure — when Barbie's there, she's not in
pink Kansas anymore.
The only way Barbie can have a "giant party
with planned choreography and a bespoke song"
every night in Barbie Land is with a stacked
soundtrack.
So far, Nicki Minaj, Ice Spice, Lizzo, Kid
LAROI, HAIM, Charlie XCX, Tame Impala, Ava
Max, Dominic Fike, KAROL G, PinkPantheress,
and FIFTY FIFTY are confirmed to grace the
soundtrack with their pink and powerful presences.
Maybe we'll even get more of Aqua than the
sample used in the movie trailer implies.
The album is executive produced by hitmaker
Mark Ronson, who personally requested Dua
Lipa work on a song for a major set piece
in the movie.
According to his own Instagram post, Mark
Ronson DM'd Dua Lipa a request to work on
the movie, calling the movie "hilarious."
Dua's song will score a 60-person dance scene
in the movie.
"Dance the Night" also has its own music video,
featuring a cameo by Greta Gerwig.
While the "Barbie News"-themed "Barbie the
Album" cover promises "more Barbies and Kens
to be announced," there's one more Ken musician
we're excited about — the Kennest Ken of
them all, Ryan Gosling.
While this might shock some fans of the actor,
others might be familiar with his musical
side from "La La Land" and "Lars and the Real
Girl," or his former band Dead Man's Bones.
Real ones know Gosling's come a long way from
his "Mickey Mouse Club" days, even if his
Ken costumes beg to differ.
Every interview Ryan Gosling grants about
playing Ken in the "Barbie" movie is better
than the last.
Even though, according to the movie, Ken's
job is "just beach," Gosling had a hard time
getting a handle on his character at first.
He told the crowd at CinemaCon,
"I didn't know Ken from within and if I'm
being really honest, I doubted my Kenergy.
I didn't see it, but Margot and Greta, they
conjured this out of me somehow.
It was like I was living my life and then
one day I was bleaching my hair, shaving my
legs, wearing bespoke neon outfits, and rollerblading
down Venice beach."
Gosling also spoke at CinemaCon about how
Robbie helped him tap into his elusive Kenergy,
saying,
"She left a pink present with a pink bow,
from Barbie to Ken, every day while we were
filming.
They were all beach-related.
Like puka shells, or a sign that says 'Pray
for surf.'"
If Gerwig and Robbie helped Gosling achieve
internal mental Ken fitness, he was on his
own to attain Ken's considerable physical
fitness, which was no mean feat.
"That Ken life is even harder than 'The Gray
Man' life, I think."
Even before the "Barbie" movie's release,
the brand's iconic aesthetic inspired a fashion
trend called "Barbiecore."
Think pink — like, neon pink — and a playful,
poppy aesthetic that leans into frills, "girly"
energy, and all things toy-like and fabulous.
A quick search of "Barbiecore" on TikTok returns
gazillions of views on posts featuring looks
popping with pink.
Pastel, shimmer, magenta, fuschia, neon — the
pink sky's the limit.
Vogue reports that the look has taken over
runway fashion as well, especially with Versace's
recent sparkling (and movie-ready) fashions.
Tourism boards are taking advantage of the
sudden interest in "Barbiecore" as well, with
California creating a "Barbiecore Tour Through
California" campaign for those who prefer
their pink with a touch of '60s-inflected
style.
Some "Barbiecore" is even a direct result
of the meta-world of the movie.
When Barbie leaves behind Barbie Land for
the "real" world, she and Ken skate through
Venice Beach on skates they brought from home,
based on the iconic blades of '90s Barbies.
Impala Skate is releasing tie-in skates and
pads that exactly match the ones Barbie and
Ken wear in the movie.
Soon, real-life Barbies and Kens can buy their
own to live their own plastic and fantastic
Barbiecore lifestyle — if they aren't already
sold out.
Issa Rae, who plays President Barbie in the
"Barbie" movie, is a legendary writer, director,
actor, and producer.
Known for making and starring in hit shows
like "Insecure," Rae knows a thing or two
about creating powerful pop culture — and
good leadership.
Rae has openly praised the energy and leadership
on the "Barbie" set.
Rae told PopSugar,
"Literally everybody on that set was just
great vibes, great to be around.
It starts at the top...
You have two people, your lead and your director,
who are both women, I must say.
They're just both incredible people and incredibly
talented.
They made it a comfort zone."
Initially, Rae wasn't fully on board with
Gerwig's pitch for the Barbie movie, just
the director's enthusiasm for the idea.
But when Rae got to the script, she told The
Hollywood Reporter,
​​"Reading it was, like, 'Oh my God, I
love her even more.'
And then actually shooting it, it was incredible,
one of my favorite experiences."
Will Ferrell plays the CEO of Mattel in the
film, who so far looks like the movie's villain.
While Ferrell isn't exactly a victim of CEO
typecasting, this isn't the first time Ferrell
has played a slightly villainous institutional
figure that breaks the laws of reality while
wearing a suit and tie.
Ferrell plays a Dad who just doesn't understand
his kid in "The LEGO Movie" — until, of
course, his kid and his LEGO remind him of
the power of play.
His costume for "Barbie" is incredibly similar
to that in "The LEGO Movie," except in "Barbie"
his tie is pink, of course.
Perhaps the movie's themes share a common
thread?
Ferrell has also played the wildly creative
fashion designer overlord Mugatu, the silly
and villainous character in "Zoolander."
Ferrell is good at playing over-the-top, yet
grounded characters, whether in suit-and-tie
or haute couture.
He adored being in "Barbie," telling the Wall
Street Journal,
"It's a loving homage to the brand and, at
the same time, couldn't be more satirical
[...] Just an amazing comment on male patriarchy
and women in society and why Barbie's criticized
and yet why every little girl still wants
to play with Barbie."
Barbie has been in development for a long
time, first with Amy Schumer set to star,
and later with Anne Hathaway attached.
Some time after that, Margot Robbie and her
husband's production company, LuckyChap, scooped
up the property.
While it might seem obvious that Robbie would
consider herself an iconic blonde, for the
role of an iconic blonde, she actually wasn't
her own first choice.
Robbie tells The Hollywood Reporter about
LuckyChap,
"We never started a company to be a starring
vehicle for me.
We wanted to expand what female stories and
female storytellers could do in this industry,
and I don't need to be onscreen for that to
happen."
So it tracks that Robbie initially thought
Gal Gadot would be a perfect fit for the role
of the beautiful, sweet, and super-sincere
doll.
Robbie tells Vogue,
"Gal Gadot is Barbie energy.
She's so genuinely sincere, and she's so enthusiastically
kind, that it's almost dorky.
It's like right before being a dork."
While the story of the "Barbie" movie has
been kept mostly mysterious leading up to
its release, it's clearly meant to be a magical,
existential tale meant to appeal to kids and
adults.
While Gerwig and the rest of the cast and
crew have playfully only teased that "Barbie"
is going to subvert expectations, Greta has
shared some of her more philosophical inspirations:
a trip to Mattel and an old book.
Gerwig tells Vogue about "meeting" the many
versions of Barbie at Mattel,
"All of [the dolls] are Barbie, and Barbie
is everyone.
Philosophically, I was like, Well, now that's
interesting."
The amount and variety of Barbies inspired
Gerwig, who said it gave her "an expansive
idea of self that we could all learn from."
Gerwig also shared with Vogue that a parenting
guide book she read as a kid, "Reviving Ophelia,"
kept coming up when she was writing "Barbie."
The book is about raising teenage girls and
the depression they may face during the changes
of adolescence.
Gerwig related that to Barbie's, saying,
"How is this journey the same thing that a
teenage girl feels?
All of a sudden, she thinks, Oh, I'm not good
enough."
"Do you guys ever think about dying?"
Margot Robbie and Greta Gerwig know that Barbie
as a toy is beloved and be-hated in equal
measure.
Barbie is a significant cultural figure, sometimes
for good and sometimes for bad.
She is a symbol of empowerment, adventure,
and acceptance — as well as, at times, body
image issues, impossible beauty standards,
and vapidity.
Robbie and Gerwig decided to use all of that
in their movie.
Robbie told Vogue,
"We have to acknowledge that there are a lot
of people who aren't fans of Barbie.
They actively hate Barbie.
And have a real issue with Barbie.
We need to find a way to acknowledge that."
While it remains to be seen exactly how the
not-so-sparkly side of Barbie will be handled
in the movie, the thoughtful and playful sound
bites sound promising.
The sense of play the entire creative team
has been showcasing has audiences feeling
like kids again.